let's say that we had a time management
course we sell for 19 bucks if I drilled
down and made it a sales time management
course I might be able to sell that for
$99 if I nich down even further and said
outbound sales reps I might be able to
sell that for $500 if I nich down even
further I might say Automotive outbound
sales reps I might be able to sell that
same course for $2,000 the difference
between the $19 thing and the $2,000
thing is a 100x difference in price and
we're able to achieve that because the
Avatar that we're selling it to we can
clearly demonstrate how much one
additional sale could mean for them in
their paycheck over the year or maybe
one more sale per month and then
dramatically show the discrepancy
between what they're paying and what
they're getting